قام elon musk بتغريد أنه كان له تأثير على السوق ،
لكن اتضح أنه كان يمزح فقط يوم
الثلاثاء في تغريدة المسك الليلية
إلى 103
مليون متابع ، قال أيضًا إنني
أشتري مانشستر يونايتد ، فمرحبًا بك
، وبعد ذلك بساعات قال المسك إنه كان
كل شيء  نكتة تغرد
لا ، هذه مزحة طويلة على
تويتر ، أنا لا أشتري أي فريق رياضي ،
فهل هذا قليل من الضرر ولا
ضرار أو يمكن أن يواجه المسك تدقيقًا
من الثانية
لأن نادي كرة القدم الإنجليزي
شركة يتم تداولها علنًا ، دعنا نحضر  في
cnn's claire
claire duffy لتشريح كل هذا ،
أريد أن أسألك لأن الثانية
ليست معروفة تمامًا
بحس الفكاهة الكبير ، أتساءل عما إذا كنت تعتقد
أن المسك في أي نوع من المخاطر
القانونية لهذا لأن مانشستر
قفزت الأسهم التي تتداول في نيويورك لفترة
وجيزة بنسبة 17 في المائة في مرحلة ما قبل السوق
بعد أن قام بالتغريد على هذا ما تعتقد أنه
حق فانيسا ، هذا ليس
شيئًا يمكنك المزاح بشأنه
خاصة إذا كنت شخصًا مثل  إيلون
المسك الذي  يعرف أنه قادر على
تحريك الأسواق ، أقصد أن إيلون ماسك يمكنه
التغريد عن dogecoin وإرسال سعر السهم
طائرًا وهكذا في هذه الحالة تعرف متى
إذا كنت سأغرد عن شراء
فريقي الرياضي المفضل ، فإن الناس سيفترضون
أنها كانت مزحة لأنني  لا يستطيع تحمل
ذلك ولكن تقدر قيمة مانشستر يونايتد
بأقل من خمسة مليارات دولار ، وهذا
شيء يجب أن يتحمله بسهولة
ولذا على الجميع أن يقولوا نوعًا ما إذا
كان يمزح هل هو لا يمزح كما تعلم
بلومبيرج أفاد ليلة الثلاثاء
أن مالكي مانشستر يونايتد  سيكون على
استعداد لبيع حصة أقلية في
النادي وأنت تعرف ذلك على الرغم من أن إيلون ماسك
بعد أربع ساعات من تغريدة على تويتر الأولي
قال إن هذا كله كان مجرد سهم مزاح
لا يزال يرتفع صباح يوم الأربعاء ،
وهذا شيء أعتقد أنه قد يكون جيدًا جدًا.
انظر إلى ما تعلم أنه لا يمكنك
إلقاء مزحة بشأن شراء شركة يتم تداولها علنًا ،
لذلك قد ينظر الثواني في هذا الأمر
، وقد يرسلون إلى إيلون ماسك بعض الأسئلة
حول ما كان يفكر في القيام به  إنه
يعرف جيدًا في هذه المرحلة ،
ما إذا كانوا يتخذون أي إجراء
بشأن هذا الأمر ، أعتقد أنه غير واضح نوعًا
ما والتحدي الذي يواجهه في الثانية مع
شخص مثل إيلون ماسك هو أن
العلاج الوحيد لهم هو غرامة وعندما
تجد  أغنى رجل في
العالم قد لا يكون
رادعًا كافيًا لمنعه من قول أشياء
مثل هذه
لك